ah
my [ __ ] I was definitely her crazy in
the morning
I don't know man I fall down so much
somebody told me not to talk about my
ass that's right here
you know I don't know it I spy now
I have somebody help
see what it is
that shouldn't be this white man I know
I shouldn't
all right Naomi yes
Naomi uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally we're operating from
uh uh I said
where's that it's a way out a way off
the map it's away from here uh right uh
several years right
Five Ten Years Later
eight uh five percent six seven eight
years I had nine years almost ten years
from here two years from now
for being 10 years from way way from
here I want to get out and travel you
know because my first time hey where I
had business too and when I got here
because it's kind of screwed up but [ __ ]
they say I can wait so they get my uh
penalty of my house and hey uh what I
got to do because I say they take care
of houses and business down here hey uh
what I think Naomi yeah tell me what
your family growing up as a child not by
any uh but they was very curious I mean
very much like they are now their head
always worried about me everywhere I go
you know in my own house
hey uh they uh love me a lot they uh hug
me and keep me together everything I
need you know they bring it to me and I
pay up sometimes they pay they uh I eat
very well and uh I thank God we go uh
church and all that and we have uh
meetings and stuff like that about our
lives and well my mom and dad they
always there of everything I'm I'm into
they raised me they kept me close and
everything that kept me in graduate
school a technique you know technique
for purposes where I want to be uh I
said I want to be a king one day and
they say sure and one day uh make sure I
got that position for hey whatever
my mom and dad they loved me to death
about what I want to be and all that you
know to keep me cold right here when
someone hurt me you're down there and
they describe it they just talk about it
as soon as you change it says clear up
so it ain't in my head no more and
whatever
you know I I have some some property I
was there for my stomach and everything
you're living on the streets now right
yes right now I mean like seven eight
years 15 years I've been out here so 25
something like that too long tell me
about living on the streets uh well hey
it's hard it's every day you fight with
someone hey they want your stuff they
they they won't feed you after y'all get
up and ask people for money and change
to ask for jobs around and waiting not a
baby somebody said something about you
and your ass and what every time you
want to know them and well whatever and
I just I get up and ask for Change and
it's hard to get Banks and all that
stuff I had to pay the world out of the
world your parking me man exchange and
all that hey they don't do the checks
some people checks and social security
cards some things like that on the
street Naomi where do you sleep at night
where do you go anywhere anywhere on the
side Street where other people are by
grocery stores Hey cuz I can get up in
the morning and go to a grocery store
and get a cup of coffee
hey everybody got changed
but begging down the street
you had uh bad things happen to you here
on the street yeah I got
beat up a lot of times and and they just
beating up on me every time they come
back and ask me for things oh man oh old
people can ask me for sex I got some
time I need it but sometimes I don't
know sometimes they ask me too much same
people I meet them all the time where
they mess up me I wish it'd go away
sometime you know and I asked them I
said so I feel like it today they get
mad Shucks Shucks and all that [ __ ]
trying to give me more money I said not
today so uh for sex and I said no I'm
not that way
people are asking you that yeah they
want to have sex with him yeah for money
yeah and I said no I said no I'm not
that way I said I'm not gonna wear my
body out to go home you know one day I
go back home I turn the boys to watch me
but of course I'm gonna get up and go
get up and go this way get up and go
that way every time I'm comfortable they
have people come on tear my [ __ ] up or
steal my tent but the casting out hey I
meet people on the street yeah is your
is your neck hurting yeah
it feels like you had surgery on your
neck yeah I started doing this Nick
right here somebody cutting right here
one day I was sat here sleeping they had
to cut my neck and I jumped up in the
rain I didn't go to the hospital fail
and they cut my neck and see almost died
because we cut something almost in my
living hey uh what what they say it's in
people's mouth say hello to me all that
[ __ ] would have strangers come around me
all the time when I set I said no no no
I hate the way I supposed to go with my
life you know about my neck didn't hurt
me ever since then singing it and been
screwed up there how long ago was that
about five years ago man and then start
acting crazy this year man like two
years back two years back how old are
your name I um I am 64 years old
64. do you have children yes I have I
have three kids I have three sons and
two daughters
and do they know you're living like this
no they're not knowing they know I'm in
a bad position in a bad place but damn
they are not living this hard amen uh I
want to get back to my kids and my grind
but hey did you ever talk to them I
talked to them once or twice in this
year and yes and I've been here for 27
years I talked to him once or twice but
they said give back my mom and dad this
place went crazy like hell what you
gonna do about it and all that [ __ ] to
my kids face in here you know on the
phone with you my kids crying because I
said I know they all because that people
say what you gonna do about say Mom Dad
I know I already my daughter started
crying first she called one day and then
somebody helped the phone I don't know
what happened but see the man playing on
my phone and hang up yo she didn't call
back and she she said everything she
said Naomi I said what and [ __ ] and yeah
do you have any friends
uh no I have I have certain friends but
they are smokers you know hell I'll talk
to them very much do you use any of the
drugs that are on here no I do not uh
but hey I talk to friends to do but I
said they crazy they get mad and leave
you know and I'll be glad they left too
because they asked most cigarettes like
crazy you know I'm a cigarette smoke or
you know
and what I say uh shooting goes that way
in my part of my spot you know where do
you go to eat I go to floor grocery
stores to eat sometimes and sometimes I
go to restaurants how do you uh get
money I ask people I ask them up and
down I ask them for a few dollars to do
some work or something like hey bring
some down to my car and do a little
something fix it clean a face car or
some [ __ ] and get paid
I see you up walking up and down my
street my back studio and I'll see you
going to the bathroom out in public
so you can't find a bathroom you just
kind of do it out in public uh no I
can't find another bathroom so hey uh
sometime I do I'm probably because hey
that's hard you know that's love
sometime boy I go to the bathroom after
all of that and wash my hands and all
that but sometimes hey man I just
bathroom is hard to get to it out in the
bathroom crowded up so man I'm usually
bathroom on the street hey action
forgive me away from my area what's the
hardest part of living like this for you
I want to use a bathroom and uh Hey
hunger
you hungry yeah why they dance okay but
it's not okay really because that's uh
hey they make you get up every time they
see you they just know your face is
walking around areas and see your face
till you get up but what I don't know
why
hey uh but [ __ ] sometimes I understand
I'm saying man I'm tired man I don't
care you know sometimes well I should
have your body today but tomorrow two
days from now I'll be back and you gotta
be gone [ __ ] like that what uh what
emotions do you go through living this
life emotion right it feels like hey
what they say about my ass you know what
I'm saying that I know you show me all
time and I go okay okay and they go well
you can't hold too much
but hey man you said what we do man we
uh we agreed around and we get drunk and
all that [ __ ] hey [ __ ] get laid
I said why ain't that type of person
and they get mad go away you know [ __ ]
yeah what would you say is your biggest
fear
uh laying down somebody kick you up kick
you all in here and all that [ __ ]
waiting in there yeah it must be
terrified after what happened to your
neck yeah yeah uh we're having our neck
I was in the park one day so brother I
was talking to a boy she just dumped me
in the neck and said hey girl why don't
you stop me and listen sometimes
before you know she just went off on me
you know anytime my people would come
upstairs nobody know your face hey and
you talk somebody we always talk to and
she just stabbed me right here and I
said why should go out I said I didn't
know you was uh talking to this man and
she thought that's her boyfriend and all
that [ __ ] but he don't know I'm not and
he's like yeah yeah you are you know she
stands come get away hey that's my
greatest fear how did you first end up
on the streets well I came down here and
and they say uh well what we do today I
said I wanted my house to go no no way
we have no papers in your house but they
do and [ __ ] but they talked to me for
about six months to a year of five years
and I said yes I'm ready to go man what
you gonna do about my house fix my door
now I'm naughty they said well uh I need
to run up need another life and we ain't
got a lot to go through that door your
door like that like your locked door I
said okay well hey man a hundred a man
came in one day said I got a lock for
that door Miss Miss Brooks I said what I
said okay so you gotta sit there before
a year before we to fix it I said okay
but she got them answering my address
and all that I gave them to him they
didn't they went there they said they'd
be back hey I mean I ain't heard nothing
two years after that five years later
man I haven't seen for uh 10 years later
man and I heard nothing about fixing my
door now you know because my door was
broke and it's like a [ __ ] house was no
and I came here they said right here in
America so I came to America and they
said well we'll fix your door hey how
much and they told me I paid the price
hey and then they said well well what we
do man uh we gotta waiting on us so we
get started hell he waited waiting I'm
still waiting on him he came back and
say they fixed the door halfway halfway
but it ain't always fixed I said it's
okay man that's okay there's no drug
I'll be always fixed or we're in trouble
and I said okay but hey man our day came
back and they said no more to me after
that yeah I mean do you do you have were
you in love do you have a husband or
yeah I have a husband but she uh he told
me I was sometimes he could come and say
tired he said I ain't no more ain't no
more me or nothing else to what he
believed he said there ain't no more
door he can't go to work with Castle his
door or not because you know they do his
job procedure they checked on houses
when they leave in the morning you know
somebody you work for and they make sure
his house is okay when he leaves so
you're still married yes
well I've been in the west pretty soon
because he told he called me uh last
month and told me he going to bless me
because he can't take no more hey he
gonna work some lower lady know how to
say she know I picked her [ __ ] up hey I
told him well hey I can't do nothing
about this until they do that I said
they slow as Christmas I said what can I
do about it he go well uh hey I'm tired
of waiting on it no kind of [ __ ] is that
I said well maybe I fix it good well one
won't mess up no more ever in his life
even the door brought that the door be
stuck on the door with her for the house
well what she said okay well you know he
ain't called me back since in about five
six years and amen I'm waiting on his
call for some [ __ ] you know like you
know what he gonna say about he'll give
me an answer about the door you know
they must not doing nothing about my
daughter it's got me then I can sleep on
money you know see I'm saying oh they
broke me already going down the street
buying things here but uh boy now I was
in hotels and all that [ __ ] but the man
they broke broke my courage buying
clothes and all that [ __ ] they come in
breaking and steal help me uh so I quit
[ __ ] around so they said go outside
it won't let me in business no more I
mean you have bad record and all that
[ __ ] about coming in people still
knocked your house here you got me and I
said what you say man they busted my
door when I open the door you know
because they don't know my ass you know
that's what they say
so what I do man I'm just sitting back I
said well I go outside and I heard that
text
so about 10 cents so I'm taking tents
away from me